SHINZO ABE:
On July 8, 2022, Shinzo Abe, Japan’s longest
serving prime minister was assassinated in
broad daylight.
Hatred for world leaders is not surprising.
Regardless of which side you choose and how
accommodating you are, someone is going to
despise you whic his completely fine.
Diversity in thought and debates are one of
the key factors pushing forward humanity.
But, the problem is that when enough people
despise you, you start getting some lunatics
who end up pushing things way too far.
This is why government leaders get thousands
of death threats on an annual basis.
President George W. Bush, for example, received
3,000 threats every year, and President Barack
Obama received as much as 2 to 5 times that.
Since 1865, there have been attempts on the
lives of one of every four Presidents and
the successful assassination of one of every
five.
Despite these grim statistics, it does seem
like assassinations have been reduced in recent
history thanks to better technology and security
procedures.
It’s been 40 years since a US president
was shot and nearly 60 years since a US president
was assasinated.
These statistics were even better for Japan
who hadn’t seen an assassination since 1936.
But, unfortunately, Japan’s statistics were
just reset.
And the worst part is that the assassination
may have been prevented with some extra security
measures in place.
So, here’s exactly how Japan’s former
prime minister, Shinzo Abe, was assasainated.
THE ASSASSINATION:
The morning of July 8, 2022 started off just
like any other day for Shinzo Abe.
Though he was retired, having stepped down
from being prime minister in late 2020 due
to health concerns, Abe was still a leading
voice within Japan’s political environment.
He regularly helped his colleagues campaign
and secure their own spots within the political
hierrachy.
On this particular day, Abe was scheduled
to campaign for Sanshiro Matsuyama who was
running for the House of Councillors.
However, this event was cancelled at the last
second due to allegations growing that Matsuyama
was corrupt.
With the event cancelled, Abe could’ve taken
the day off, but he was already prepared to
give a speech and interact with the public,
so he rescheduled to campaign for Kei Sato
instead.
Sato was an LDP councillor running for reelection
and he was holding an event in Nara Prefecture.
This event was heavily marketed on social
media and through word of mouth, but due to
the last minute change, the general public
wasn’t even aware that Abe would show up
at this event.
You would think that this would’ve provided
Abe with additional safety, but that doesn’t
seem to be the case.
Anyway, the evening before the event, Nara
police and Sato’s campaign staff would inspect
the area, and they would find some red flags.
One of the biggest concerns was the amount
of car and foot traffic that was present in
the road behind the event.
Nonetheless, the security plan was approved
just a few hours before Abe arrived.
With the green light from security, Sato would
begin delivering his speech at 11:10 AM.
Abe arrived approximately 9 minutes later
and was accompanied by VIP protection officers
from both the Tokyo Metropolitan Police Department
and the Nara Prefectural Police.
Abe began his speech 10 minutes later at 11:29
AM.
It appears that the perpetrator was just waiting
for Abe to take the stage because he would
strike almost instantaneously.
At 11:30, Abe declared with enthusiasm “Instead
of thinking about why he cannot do it.”
And that was it, the first shot had gone off.
Everyone was immediately alerted, but no one
was quite sure what the sound even was.
The security guards were extremely familiar
with how a firearm sounds, but this sounded
nothing like a firearm.
It sounded more like a firework or a tire
blowout.
Everyone’s eyes frantically searched for
the source of the sound including Abe who
turned around and . The second round of shots
had been fired, and unlike the first round,
this round hit abe in both the neck and chest
areas.
Abe could feel the wind knocked out of him
as he took a few steps forward before he fell
to his knees and collapsed.
Some of his security detail immediately rushed
to Abe while others moved to detain the suspect
who didn’t resist.
It turns out that the suspect was using a
homemade firearm that was capable of firing
six bullets at the same time.
This is why the firing sound seemed so unfamiliar.
But, while the sound may have been wonky,
it was no less lethal.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE:
Abe didn’t immediately die though, he was
actually conscious shortly after the shooting
and bystanders would attempt to help him.
They began CPR as soon as possible and while
I’m sure they had good intentions, medical
experts think that this only made things worse.
Generally, the rule is to start CPR as soon
as you realize that someone has no pulse and
is not breathing, but the wounds significantly
complicated the situation.
According to one paramedic, performing CPR
on a penetrated heart would simply increase
chest trauma/bleeding.
Speaking of paramedics, paramedics would arrive
on scene just 7 minutes after the incident
at 11:37 AM and they would takeover.
4 minutes after that at 11:41 AM, an ambulance
and a doctor would arrive on scene.
But unfortunately, Abe had already lost consciousness
by this point.
Abe would be loaded into the ambulance before
being transported to a local hospital on a
helicopter within 50 minutes of being shot.
By the time he arrived at the hosptial though,
he had no vital signs likely due to cardio
pulmonary arrest.
Over the next 4 hours, doctors would administer
100 units of blood transfusions, but none
of this was enough to revive Abe.
At 4:55 PM, Abe’s wife Akie arrived at the
hospital and just 8 minutes later at 5:03
PM, Shinzo Abe was pronounced dead at age
67.
From there, a full police autospy was performed
which confirmed that Abe had been killed by
a bullet damaging an artery under his collarbone.
Japan would go on to host a state sponsored
funeral which turned out to be one of the
most controversial events of this entire saga.
This was Japan’s first state funeral since
1967 and came with a hefty price tag of $11.5
million.
And given that Japan is already undergoing
an economic crisis and an energy crisis, it’s
not surprising that many people did not want
to spend money on this funeral.
But to be honest, I doubt that the objections
were strictly objective as there’s no doubt
that politics and especially the Unification
Church played a role in this opposition.
Abe had deep ties to the Unification Chruch
which much Japan views as a cult.
And by sponsoring Abe’s funeral, many felt
that the state was indirectly supporting the
church.
One of the most notable opponents to the funeral
seems to be Japan’s royal family who did
not attend the funeral.
Many world leaders did attend the funeral
though including Kamala Harris, Narendra Modi,
Anthony Albanese, and Han Duck-soo.
And with that, the chaper of Japan’s longest
serving prime minister was over, but all of
this still leaves one question unanswered.
Why?
MOTIVE:
While Abe was an extremely controversial politician,
his demise was ironically not due to his political
views but rather his personal views and specifically
his connection to the Unification Church.
You see, the perpetrator Tetsuya Yamagami
felt that the Unification Church had robbed
his family of everything.
And that eliminating Shinzo Abe was his form
of um community service to prevent more families
from going through the same pain.
Yamagami’s hatred for the chuch started
at a very young age.
While Yamagami was born to affluent parents
who owned a construction business, his life
would be turned on its heels when his father
took his own life when Yamagami was just 4
years old.
This left his mother with the responsibility
of taking care of the business and raising
the children.
This was something that his mother was not
emotionally ready to handle so she sought
solace resulting in her eventually joining
the Unification Church when Yamagami was 11
years old.
Over the next 7 years, Yamagami’s mother
would essentially hand over the family’s
entire wealth to the church.
She gave the church $720,000, a piece of land
she had inherited from her father, and the
house that she and her children lived in.
Shortly after this, she would declare bankruptcy
in 2002.
By the time Yamagami grew up, his family had
gone from being affluent to being bankrupt,
and there was only one person Yamagami blamed:
The Unification Church.
Yamagami would join the Japanese Marine force
around the same time that his mother declared
bankruptcy, but things didn’t get better,
they only got worse.
In fact, things got so bad that in 2005, Yamagami’s
uncle contemplated taking his own life so
that his sister, Yamagami’s mother, could
get the life insurance money.
Fortuantely, he wouldn’t do it, but someone
else would: Yamagami’s brother.
Yamagami’s brother had already struggled
with cancer for a long time, and now he couldn’t
afford his medical treatment either, so he
decided to end it.
And it was at this moment that Yamagami knew
that he was going to exact his revenge.
He made it his life’s mission to take down
the Unification Church and posted things like
“I’m willing to die to liberate every
person involved in the Unification Church.”
Abe wasn’t Yamagami’s first target though.
For years, he was targeting high ranking members
of the church such as Hak Ja Han Moon who
is the leader of the church.
At one point, Yamagami was even targetting
the entire Moon family, but he knew that this
was unrealistic.
So, he shifted his focus onto someone that
would make international headlines and attract
the attention of the entire world and that
was of course Shinzo Abe.
Yamagami shared that Abe wasn’t originally
an enemy of his though he wasn’t a fan either.
But, when he realized that Shinzo Abe was
the Unification Church sympathizer who wielded
the most influence in the real world, his
target was clear.
He would send a manifesto to a journalist
on July 7, 2022 and the rest is history.
PREVENTION:
One of the biggest criticisms Japan has received
is how its security detail responded to the
noise.
There was a full 2.5 seconds between the two
shots which was likely plenty of time to take
action.
But instead of lunging to cover Abe, it appears
that they didn’t exactly know what was happening
or what to do.
This has resulted in many blaming Abe’s
security for his death.
And there definitely is some truth to this.
If this was the American secret service, they
probably would’ve had a much better shot
at protecting Abe.
Just take a look at how they protect Donald
Trump after a noise that clearly wasn’t
even a firearm.
The key thing to note though is that, as sad
as it is, the US is used to gun violence.
Not to mention, citizens are able to legally
own firearms and 6 US presidents have already
been shot.
So, looking out for this is at the top of
their mind.
The same, however, cannot be said about Japan
who has extremely strict laws surrounding
firearms.
In all of 2021, for example, only 1 person
was killed by gun violence across all of Japan.
During the same time period, the US experienced
over 45,000 deaths.
I think you can see why Abe’s security was
likely caught off guard.
We should also note that they weren’t even
protecting the current prime minister.
They were protector a former prime minister
who had already been retired for nearly 2
years, so you would think that this would
further reduce the chances of something like
this taking place, but unfortunately not.
While Shinzo Abe may no longer be with us,
there’s no question that his impact is here
to stay.
According to his supporters, Abe was a ruthless
pragmatist who aimed to build a strong Japan
though Abenomics.
According to his haters, Abe was a fierce
nationalist and historical revisionist who
only cared about increasing his own power.
But, regardless of which side your own, I
think we can all agree that this is tragedy
that we don’t want to see repeated in any
country.
Were you aware of this terrible tragedy?
Comment that down below Also, drop a like
if you hope Abe rests in peace.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.